so you're born on the Trap House couch
who was your mom an addict at the time
or was she there with your dad who was
an addict what's going on no yes I my
mom was um Air Force military you know
Goody Two-Shoes from Southern California
my dad uh Rough Around the Edges from
Colorado
um you know when my parents first got
together and my dad came home he said
that he was marrying a Staff Sergeant in
the military and they thought my dad was
gay
yeah
so you know he's the computer
intelligence of you know wait the club
the club mindedness about that comment
yeah first of all it couldn't be a woman
doing that job and second of all our
son's [__] gay
the Honeydew with y'all subscribe today
[Music]
okay